[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présentent le club des
territoires et avec nous aujourd'hui
pour ce club le politologue Pascal Pino
bonjour Pascal merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous et Steve Jourdin bonjour St
évidemment tout le monde vous connaît
nos téléspectateurs vous connaissent
mais ce qu' savent peut-être pas c'est
que vous êtes également docteur en
histoire et auteur de ce livre on va le
voir Israël autopsie d'une gauche 1905
1995 c'est aux éditions le bord de l'eau
merci d'être avec nous Quentin
évidemment nous a rejoint club spécial
sur la situation en Israël et
l'intervention d'Emmanuel Macron hier
soir le chef de l'État qui a apporté un
soutien ferme à Israël et les appels à
une réponse forte et juste on va y
revenir il a également parlé des otages
lancé un appel à l'unité fustigé ceux
qui confondent la cause palestinienne et
la justification du terrorisme et
Quentin il y a eu des réactions
politiques évidemment voilà on va faire
le tour effectiv ement de toutes les
réactions politiques depuis hier soir on
verra ça précisément et cette
intervention a fait également la une de
la presse régionale on en parle tout de
[Musique]
suite et pour en parler on va à Vichy
retrouver Mathieu Perino bonjour Mathieu
merci d'être avec nous responsable de
l'agence de Vichy à la rédaction du
journal La Montagne on va évidemment
Mathieu parler avec vous et vous en
parler ce matin de cette intervention
d'Emmanuel Macron
ouais tout a été dit ou presque sur
l'attaque terroriste du Hamas et sur la
riposte d'Israël et le moindre mot peut
encore ajouter de de l'huile sur le feu
pourtant la France elle est obligée de
dire de mettre des mots sur la situation
Moyen-Orient parce que c'est la France
et parce qu'en terme politique et
surtout diplomatique le silence est soit
un aveu d'impuissance soit une caution
morale alors peut-on compatir avec la
douleur des Israéliens et reconnaître le
droit à l'État d'Israël d'assurer sa
sécurité sans soutenir un gouvernement
d'extrême droite qui comprend notamment
des religieux fanatiques peut-on
compatir à ce qu'enduire le peuple
palestinien depuis des décennies sans se
montrer complaisant avec les actes
terroristes perpétrés par les islamistes
du Hamas euh on voit bien il faut dire
les choses mais en les soupesant au gram
près c'est ce qu'a essayé de faire hier
soir le président de la République une
parole nécessaire selon notre
éditorialiste florenodtal ce matin dans
les dans les colonnes des quotidiens du
groupe centre-fance elle explique il
suffit d'une presse d'une paresse
intellectuelle d'enfants gâtés et d'une
courte vue clientéliste pour que
l'histoire redevienne tragique selon
elle il n'y a pas de place pour les
ambiguïés quand la cruauté s'abat de
manière aussi aveugle sur les civils sur
les enfants dès lors le message d'unité
de paix mais aussi de fermeté adressé
par Emmanuel Macron s'imposait Emmanuel
Macron donc qui marche sur un fil entre
la reconnaissance de cette attaque
terroriste son inquiétude il l'a dit
d'un engrenage tragique ses négociations
pour leur r tour des otages et surtout
sa volonté que le conflit ne soit pas
importé sur le sol français et justement
c'est aussi l'un des sujets les risques
d'importation de ce conflit Mathieu
ouais c'est la crainte est vraiment là
désormais hein si le président a appelé
à l'Union nationale c'est qu'il sait que
la société française est vraiment
inflammable la France compte la
communauté juive la plus importante
d'Europe près de 500000 personnes
elleabrite également 6 millions de
personnes de confession musulmane la
position officielle de la France a
toujours été la recherche d'un certain
équilibre dans le traitement du conflit
israélo-palestinien mais cette fois le
statut quo il est vraiment encore plus
délicat on l'a vu politiquement les
dirigeants de LFI ont été mis à l'index
par le reste de la classe politique le
garde des saau appelé de son côté à la
plus grande fermeté contre ceux qui pr
qui qui présente les attaques du Hamas
comme une légitime résistance à Israël
il vise notamment la sphère trotskiste
don le NPA le ministre de l'Intérieur
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure a déjà
recensé 101 actes antisémites de depuis
dans le pays depuis samedi et plus de
580 synagogues écoles juives ou lieux de
culte associatif ont vu leur sécurité
renforcé tout ça en moins d'une semaine
et aujourd'hui son un sondage deslab
pour BFM TV 68 % de Français 2 tiers des
Français pensent que le conflit présente
un risque de tension en France une
crainte d'autant plus légitime que les
réseaux sociaux alimentent cette e et
que le Hamas maîtrise très bien ses
réseaux sociaux le Hamas qui a
d'ailleurs appelé aujour aujourd'hui
jour de prière pour les musulmans à
manifester partout dans le monde arabe
merci Mathieu merci d'avoir été avec
nous on regarde la une de la montagne
guerre Israël Hamas que craindre pour la
France c'est à la Une de votre journal
merci beaucoup Mathieu Perino d'avoir
été avec nous avant de vous entendre
Pascal Perino et et Steve on va revoir
les temps forts de l'intervention
d'Emmanuel Macron hier soir c'est avec
Samia de chien une condamnation sans
appel pour sa première prise de parole
depuis l'attaque terroriste du Hamas sur
Israël le chef de l'État a adressé un
message de soutien sans faille à l'État
hébreu et aux familles des otages
français je parle en notre nom à tous
quand je dis que nous partageons le
chagrin d'Israël que nous pensons à la
terreur éprouvée par les Israéliens
comme nous nous inquiétons pour le sort
de nos 17 compatriotes enfants et
adultes portés disparus et sans doute
pour certains d'entre eux retenu en
otage je pense ce soir aux familles je
veux leur dire que la France met tout en
œuvre au côté des autorités israéliennes
et avec nos partenaires pour les faire
revenir saint et sauf dans leur foyer
car jamais la France n'abandonne ses
enfants sans condamner la riposte
d'Israël sur la bande de Gaza Emmanuel
Macron a appelé à une réponse juste
épargnant les civils Israël a le droit
de se défendre en éliminant les groupes
terroristes dont le Hamas par des
actions ciblées mais en préservant les
populations civiles car c'est là le
devoir des démocraties sans citer
nommément la France insoumise le chef de
l'État a regretté son refus de qualifier
le has d'organisation terroriste ceux
qui confondent la cause palestinienne et
la justification du terrorisme
commettent une faute morale politique et
stratégique dans l'après-midi Emmanuel
Macron avait rencontré les chefs des
différents partis politiques français il
a appelé à l'unité nationale notre
devoir dans ce moment que nous vivons
est de rester uni comme nation et comme
République c'est ce bouclier de l'unité
qui nous protègera de tous les
débordements de toutes les dérives de
toutes les haines face aux craintes
d'une montée de l'antisémitisme en
France Emmanuel Macron a promis la plus
grande sévérité de la justice Pascal
Perino il a trouvé les mot justes hier
soir le chef de l'État oui je crois
qu'on peut considérer que le Président
de la République a trouver le ton juste
sur un dossier qui n'est pas
simple étant donné en effet que ce
conflit a objectivement des chances de
s'importer on le voit déjà au sein de de
l'exagone il a trouvé le ton juste parce
que la condamnation du Hamas est claire
et définitive et même il affirme le
droit d'Israël à se défendre de cette
attaque dans des conditions sur
lesquelles revenu deuxièmement il dit au
fond que le principe bien sûr de
l'existence de l'État d'Israël ne peut
pas être remis en cause or une lecture
même de la version la plus récente de la
charte du Hamas montre qu'il n'y a pas
de place pour eux pour un état israélien
ce qu'ils appellent l'antité sioniste
hein troisièmement je crois qu'il a été
il a trouvé les mots justes également
euh vis-à-vis des Français en ce qui
concerne la question des otages 17 et
des morts français 13 morts et là il a
réaffirmé la volonté de la France de
protéger comme il le dit ses ses enfants
et enfin bon il dit que voilà ce conflit
est extrêmement long parce que il dure
depuis
1948 ce conflit avec déjà les mêmes
questions deux états et cetera euh donc
il dure depuis
1948 mais voilà il faudra bien un jour
trouver une solution de paix mais pour
l'instant soyons pas naïf c'est la
guerre qui parle et qui quelque part it
parler on va en parler hein Steve
Emmanuel Macron qui a dit clairement son
soutien ferme à Israël mais qui dans le
même temps dit qu'il est légitime
qu'Israël y poste mais mais qu'il faut
une réponse forte et juste est-ce que
c'est une manière de dire à Israël qu'il
faut pas aller trop loin c'est une
manière de de de d'anticiper les jours
qui vont qui vont venir Israël a donné
un ultimatum à la population Gazaoui 1
million de personnes qui doivent aller
vers le sud de Gaza on on peut
s'attendre maintenant à une une
incursion terrestre on s'y attendait
déjà depuis quelques jours vous
mobilisez pas 360000 réservistes pour
rien c'est la plus grande mobilisation
une des plus grandes mobilisations de
l'histoire d'Israël la dernière dernière
fois je crois que c'était en 73 au
moment de la guerre du Kipour qui
ressemble à bien des égards à ce qu'on a
vécu la semaine dernière donc donc oui
Emmanuel Macron sait que dans les jours
les jours qui viennent la positionition
française va être de plus en plus
délicate et il a rappelé la solution
diplomatique française de pour de peupes
vivre en côte à côte un état israélien
un État palestinien dans le contexte
actuel c'est presque inaudible mais il
est obligé de tracer quelques
perspectives Emmanuel Macron il peut pas
se contenter de dire on donne carte
blanche à Israël et voilà parce que dans
les jours encore une fois dans les jours
qui viennent la la la perception ne sera
plus la même mais sur la repost est-ce
que c'est aussi un message à Benjamin
netaniaahou qui est très martial hein
depuis samedi sur le fait qu'il veut
écraser le Hamas que le le prix à payer
sera sans précédent est-ce qu'Emmanuel
Macron a dit attention Israël c'est une
une démocratie il faut faire attention
au civil c'était ça le message il peut
le dire il peut le dire maintenant benan
ne l'écoutera sans doute pas Joe Biden
avait dit la même chose mardi dans son
élocution il donne carte blanche à
Israël en demandant de respecter les
règles de l'État de droit donc c'est
effectivement il trace quelques petite
ligne rouge mais il y a un mot qu'il a
pas prononcé Emmanuel Macron hier c'est
le mot C c'est le feu il n pas prononcé
le mot C c'est le feu et ça c'est très
important la réponse doit être forte et
juste c'est ça là on est dans la phase
de la force on verra si la force
peut-être une force juste et dit forte
parce que juste oui oui oui bien sûr
force parce que juste parce que c'est
vrai que il y a un combat vis-à-vis de
l'opinion publique mondiale hein et que
la riposte
israélienne ne doit
pas
focaliser toutes les haines l'attente
les antisémitismes ou antisionism variés
qui existe dans le monde quelque part
l'image d'Israël est une image blessée
euh mais c'est une image il faut savoir
qui n'a pas été dans les années passées
l'image dominante d'Israël Israël avait
l'image en effet avec en plus de ça
l'évolution euh du centre de gravité
politique du gouvernement israélien
pouvait avoir l'image d'un gouvernement
euh euh agressif euh et il faut que euh
voilà les Israéliens soient euh euh
attentif à la nature de leur réponse
d'ailleurs ce que vient de dire l'armée
israélienne en disant voilà dans les 24
heures il faut que la population Gazaoui
se détache quelque part de l'emprise
d'amas et partte vers le Sud va dans ce
sens on verra si une telle comment dire
une telle migration de plus d'un million
euh de personnes est possible dans les
24 he immigration que ne souhaite pas le
hamason parce que le le Hamas est caché
dans des tunnels souvent dans les
maisons de la population civile et se
sert de cette population civile pour
enclencher une éventuelle Rost ou pour
entraîner en tout cas Israël à
l'intérieur de cette bande de Gaza juste
pour appeler quelques chiffres on
parlait des réservis 360000 on compte
35000 combattants terroristes du Hamas
dans la bande de Gaza dans un dans des
combats qui vont se passer maintenant
dans des ruelles dans des souterrains
dans des impasses on peut imaginer
l'ampleur de ce qui nous attend dans les
heures dans les jours qui viennent ça
rejoint ce que je disais sur voilà
Emmanuel Macron qui sait que les jours à
venir vont être compliqués donc il a
pris quelques petits précaution quand
même ouais et puis il y a la question
des otages évidemment la question des
agesulté notamment dans la reposte
d'Israël et là Emmanuel Macron a été
très clair jamais la France n'abandonne
ses enfants d'accord mais la France
n'est pas le seul acteur d'ailleurs il
l'a dit voilà il y aura plusieurs
puissances qui vont intervenir d'abord
parce que beaucoup de puissances sont
concerné par ces otages je crois qu'il y
a plus de 20 nationalités parmi les
otages que retient que retient le Hamas
donc beaucoup d'Inter loocuteurs sont
concernés et j'écoutais hier un des
directeurs du ministère des Affaires
étrangères israélien qui disait quelque
chose d'intéressant il disait la France
on l'attend oui dans la région mais on
l'attend plutôt du côté de la frontière
nord dans euh la frontière libanaise
hein euh et là la France pourrait jouer
un rôle étant donné ses liens avec le
Liban à Gaza disait-il l'affaire reste
une affaire israélienne ouais est-ce que
la la philosophie est la même du côté
israélien Steve est-ce que clairement
Israël fait une croix sur ses otages en
privilégi en une réose d'ampleur et
massive il y a une doctrine historique
côté israélien en matière d'otage ça
s'appelle la doctrine Hannibal ça a été
développé dans les années 80 et qui dit
finalement quand on a un otage entre les
mains des ennemis et bien on est pai à P
on est on va tout on fait tout pour
libérer cet otage on ne laisse pas un
Israélien un soldat israélien entre les
mains des les ennemis quittent à à payer
du du prix voilà de de la vie de cet
otage ou des populations civiles là
c'est un peu différent parce que cette
doctrine a été élaboré dans les années
80 en matière de soldats israéliens là
c'est des populations civiles qui ne
sont pas toutes israéliennes donc il
faut prendre ça en compte euh mais ça va
jouer dans la roste d'Israël le fait de
dire qu'il y a plus il y a plusieurs
otages ça va évidemment jouer puisque
vous avez l'ami américain qui qui est là
et qui suit la la la la situation de de
très près il faut voir que personne a
envie côté occidental de voir des otages
exécutés en direct euh par le Hamas
comme on a pu voir avec daesh imaginez
Joe Biden 1 an avant la présidentielle
voir des otages américains euh tués en
direct imaginez des otages français
c'est c'est très voilà c'est très
sensible euh israël va devoir prendre ça
en compte mais Israël va aussi devoir
prendre en compte ses intérêts dans
cette affaire parce que le plus grand
nombre d'otage est israélien aujourd'hui
et euh Israël a subi une attaque il va
devoir répondre comme comme il l'entend
comme il en gardant effectivement en
préservant et bien la la l'opinion
internationale qui pour l'instant va
dans son sens mais pour combien de temps
voilà on va suivre ça dans les prochains
jours et Emmanuel Macron qui a aussi mis
en garde contre une extension du conflit
au pays- voisin c'est le risque
aujourd'hui c'est un risque mais le
risque majeur c'est frappant lorsqu'on
lit la presse israélienne lorsqu'on
écoute que ce soit la gauche ou la
droite israélienne les Israéliens se
disent que la question aujourd'hui c'est
la question de l'existence même de
l'État d'Israël on a la même
problématique en 67 c'est-à-dire Israël
là a véritablement l'impression qu'il y
a un risque pour le destin de l'état de
l'État d'Israël et cela va justifier
certainement l'ariposte d'ampleur qui a
commencé et la volonté de faire en sorte
que l'Iran ne devienne pas un acteur
j'allais dire du premier rang euh le
bombardement par exemple de
d'aérodrome en en en Syrie correspond
certainement à cela puisque un avion
iranien qui était sur le chemin de ces
aéroports a été obligé à la suite de ces
bombardement de faire retour et je ne
crois pas qu'il y avait au sein de cet
avion essentiellement de paisibles
touristes iranien s il y a un risque
d'embrasement aujourd'hui de la région
clairement mais l'embrasement existe
voilà existe est déjà là d'une certaine
manière déjà là euh
soupçonneiran d'être derrière évidemment
c'est cette cette attaque vu la
coordination vu l'ampleur de de ce qui
s'est passé vous parliez Pascal de de
ces bombardement notamment en Syrie ils
sont assez réguliers parce que c'est un
chemin c'est c'est la route par laquelle
voilà l'Iran transporte des armes vers
le hzbollah Libanais ce sont des frappes
qui sont qui qui interviennent assez
assez régulièrement l'embrasement et
avec le hzbola dans dans le Sud Liban et
le le Nord Israël est-ce que il y a des
craintes aussi fortes sur cette zone ce
qui est intéressant c'est que Israël
regardait vers cette frontière regardeer
vers la frontière nord ça fait plusieurs
mois plusieurs années que Israël est
rivé sur la frontière nord et anticipe
une attaque du hzbolah l'ataque parce
qu' avait déjà eu une opération
militaire au milieu des années 2000 2006
2007 2006 il y a eu les années 80 au
Liban c'est c'est effectivement et et
craignait beaucoup plus le Hezbollah
libanais qui est mieux mé qui est mieux
organisé qui est une organisation
tentaculaire et qui a des liens directs
avec avec l'Iran donc Israël regardait
vers le nord et l'attaque est venu du
sud c'est c'est ce qui s'est passé il y
a aussi la question du Qatar alors
Emmanuel Macron il a dit qu'il avait
échangé avec plusieurs dirigeants de la
région et il a cité le Qatar c'est une
question qu'il va falloir poser ça aussi
la la question de nos relations avec le
Qatar ça c'est pas à moi tellement de de
le dire ce qui est vrai c'est que le le
le Qatar faut le savoir que que le Qatar
parle avec Israël c'est ça peut paraître
absolument
hallucinant vu d'ici mais mais le Qatar
envoie avec l'autorisation par que le
Qatar abrite le chef du Hamas he oui il
abrite le chef du du Hamas mais le Qatar
finance le Hamas et la bande de Gaza
avec l'autorisation de Benjamin netaniao
et du gouvernement israélien Israël
pensait pouvoir s'acheter une paix
sociale entre guillemets en avec cet
argent qui arrive tous les mois au Hamas
et à la bande de Gaza avec encore une
fois la bénédiction du du gouvernement
actuel on ait vu que ça fonctionnait pas
maintenant c'est aujourd'hui le seul
canal de relation qui est envisageable
pour Israël et donc pour la France
c'està-dire c'est miser sur une
médiation Catari peut-être turque mais
ça sent plus compliqué et égyptienne
pour libérer les otages pour au moins
libérer les femmes les enfants c'est
peut-être vers ce vers quoi on se dirige
aujourd'hui libération des femmes et des
enfants et la conservation entre
guillemets des des soldats israéliens
dans les mains du Hamas on va parler des
réactions politiques à ce discours
d'Emmanuel Macron Quentin globalement
unanimité politique depuis depuis samedi
d'ailleurs depuis le début très peu de
voix discordante oui très peu de voix
discordante on peut le dire et cela
c'est vu encore hier ça a commencé le
midi avec une séquence à l'Élysée les
chefs de parties étaient reçus au format
je cite Saint-Denis
exceptionnel Saint-Denis c'était le
format avec les les chefs de parti mais
pour le soir et donc là c'est
exceptionnel c'est resserré pour le midi
selon son entourage Emmanuel Macron en
fait voulait ce rendez-vous pour
favoriser je cite l'unité de la nation
alors il y a eu quelques nuances quand
même dans les réactions de la part des
oppositions voilà à droite on insiste
sur les aides françaises et européennes
qu'il faut suspendre selon le chef de
fil des LR écoutez Erric chtil l'a redit
ce matin sur RTL c'é il y a quelques
minutes on sait que l'Autorité
palestinienne aujourd'hui ne contrôle
plus rien on sait qu'il y a beaucoup de
corruption et on sait qu'au final une
part importante non négligeable de cet
argent qui va soit vers l'Autorité
palestinienne qui va soit vers des ONG
supposer soutenir humanitairement les
populations et détourner vers le Hamas
et imaginer qu'un €o d'argent public
français puisse participer à ce
financement doit être insupportable
le chef de l'État qui n'a pas retenu
hein cette proposition pour leur venu de
la droite et de l'extrême droite à
gauche les dirigeants ont réclamé que
Paris fasse entendre sa voix singulière
je cite en faveur de la paix et
d'ailleurs après la locution on a vu ce
tweet d'Olivier fort pour les
socialistes qui a écrit accord avec
Macron au 20h sur la condamnation du
Hamas et la solidaritté avec Israël
accord sur la solution à deux état mais
approuvé une reposte forte et juste sans
préciser la nécessité de se conformer au
droit international et la porte ouverte
à l'escalade et à l'asphixie de Gaza
écoutez également une réaction hier soir
pour la France insoumise de Manuel
bonpard c'était sur LCI on écoute je
partage la condamnation qu'a exprimé le
président de la République vis-à-vis de
ses actes ignobles qui ont été commis
par le Hamas samedi deuxièmement que
j'appuie toutes les initiatives qui vont
être pris par la France pour faciliter
notamment le retour de nos
ressortissants ou la libération des
otages qu'il soit d'ailleurs français ou
d'autres nationalité mais je trouve
dramatique et irresponsable le fait que
le Président de la République n'ait pas
eu un mot pour les victimes
palestiniennes qui meurent aujourd'hui
par centaines peut-être même par
milliers sous les bombes de l'armée
israélienne sur la bande de Gaza manuel
bonpar qui a été interrogé sur et bien
cette phrase du président de la
République he ce qui confondent la cause
palestinienne et la justification du
terrorisme commettent une faute morale
politique et stratégique et le chef de
fil ou en tout cas le coordinateur de la
France insoumise qui a dit ne pas se
sentir concerné par cette référence du
chef de l'État en tout cas l'exécutif a
annoncé la tenue prochain prochainement
d'un débat au Parlement au titre de
l'article 50-1 de la Constitution une
manière comprend d'inclure tous les
groupes politiques et de continuer à
garder un maximum de cohésion politique
face à cette crise en Israël ouais
l'enjeu pour Emmanuel Macron il a dit
aussi hier Pascal Perino c'est l'unité
bien sûr bien sûr la France souffre déjà
suffisamment de fractur en tout genre
pour ne pas rajouter à ces fractures en
tout genre celle qui a toujours existé
sur sur Israël il faut savoir d'autre
part que en effet la France a la
population juive la plus importante euh
en Europe et que d'autre part il y a 6
millions environ de musulmans en France
et qu'il ne s'agit pas du tout que ces
deux communautés en effet puissent
rentrer dans un processus euh non
seulement de méfiance la méfiance existe
bien sûr mais éventuellement
d'affrontement et il faut regarder avec
inquiétude la centaine d'actes
antisémite qui se sont développé sans en
quelques jours c'est énorme alors
certaine manière on aurait pu s'attendre
dans l'émotion à ce que des actes
antimusulmans aent lieu bah pas du tout
ce sont les actes antisémites qui se
sont imposés et ça c'est relativement
inquiétant donc il faut ça veut dire
pour vous qu'elle est déjà là cette
importation du conflit parce qu'Emmanuel
Macron il dit ne menons pas chez nous
des aventures idéologiques par imitation
bien sûr bien sûr elle est déjà là on le
voit dans quelques
manifestations
avorté d'ailleurs marqué au coin de la
violen déjà qui ont eu lieu à Paris à
Rennes à nîes je crois dans d'autres
villes tout cela montre oui qu'il y a
une véritable tension et que cette
tension faut s'efforcer de la contrôler
vous savez la France est un des pays en
Europe dans lequel une force politique
importante en l'occurrence la France
insoumise n'a pas condamné explicitement
le terrorisme du Hamas euh donc nous
nous avons une responsabilité
particulière cela veut dire quelque
chose sur le climat d'une partie
heureusement très minoritaire mais d'une
partie tout de même importante de la
population en France et Quentin le
rappelit Emmanuel Bompard c'est'est pas
sentivisé par cette phrase d'Emmanuel
Macron qui fustige ceux qui confondent
la cause palestinienne et la
justification du terrorisme il ne s'est
pas senti à tort
viser il s'est pas senti visé mais au
fond bien sûr beaucoup de leaders a
commencé par lui de et les filles
doivent être un peu maris aujourd'hui
pourquoi parce que voilà ce au travers
de l'anupè et les filles voulaient
chacheter une bonne conduite être se
présenter comme étant une grande force
de gouvernement responsable et
l'attitude adoptée par
fi sur ce dossier fait que la chose est
de plus en plus difficile et qu'
d'ailleurs tous les compagnons de
laanupes ont quitté etfi oui d'ailleurs
on voit que il y a une réflexion qui est
en cours au sein des autres autres
partis qui forment cette alliance
électorale de laanups de la nup le Parti
socialiste qui réunit un voilà un
rendez-vous aujourd'hui pour trancher
demain pour trancher le le sujet et on
voit par exemple Patrick caner le chef
de fil des sénateurs socialistes qui a
déjà dit qu'il va soutenir la
proposition de de de sortir de l'accord
de l'accord de l' laanup donc ça
pourrait se jouer dès ce weekend et on
voit les autres les autres chefs de
parti notamment les écologistes qui
regardent ça de très près parce que bien
entendu ça va avoir des des des
conséquences aussi pour eux pour leur
formation politique qui V devoir à ce
moment-là aussi dire ce qu'ils font si
ça explose des ce weekend ouis ouais
marine Tondelier qui dit également que
la position d'alfi pose problème au sein
de l'anupe mais vous le dites Pascal
tout tous les autres ont condamnés les
trois autres ont condamnés mais ils ne
quitent pas l'anupe pour le moment
est-ce que est-ce que la fracture est
inélictable oh la fracture est inéctable
pour moi elle était inélictable dès le
début ça n'est qu'une combinaison
électorale pour sauver des sièges de
députés on le comprend c'est pas les
seuls à avoir pratiqué ce type
d'alliance mais au fond il y a des des
gauches tout à fait irréconciliables
comme on dit souvent et ce caractère non
conciliable de ces gauches est en train
d'éclater au vu et auess de l'opinion
publique non juste pour revenir sur sur
ce sur le risque d'importation du
conflit je me suis beaucoup demandé en
tant qu'historien donc c'est ma
casquette d'historien pourquoi la France
pourquoi l'Europe était autant intéressé
sur au conflit Israël au palalestinien
en proche orient général derrière ça il
y a quand même 2000 ans de relation
entre juif et chrétiens il y a la
culpabilité de la choie de l'Europe il y
a toutes les tout le dossier de la
décolonisation qui a été soldé mais pas
vraiment on a vu avec l'histoire de de
l'Algérie il y a les relations entre
juifs et musulmans parce qu'elle en
parlait tout à l'heure donc c'est un
conflit qui nous touche directement qui
nous intéresse directement qui nous
interpelle tout à chacun et ce qu'on
voit qu'on est en train de voir dans
depuis depuis quelques jours est ce
qu'on va sans doute voir dans dans les
jours qui viennent c'est à quel point ce
conflit nous est un conflit français
d'une certaine manière c'est pas ça n'a
rien à voir c'est pas la même chose
c'est on ne comprend pas réellement ce
qui se passe là-bas mais ça nous touche
directement et c'est un conflit avec des
paramètres un peu différents en France
je sais pas si c'est très clair ce que
je viens de dire il y a un conflit
israelopélistien avec ses propres
paramètres et une sorte de conflit en
France avec des paramètres différents
mais qui n touche tout tout tous les
citoyens français aujourd'hui oui oui
d'une certaine manière ce ce conflit
israélo-palestinien peut apparaître de
temps en temps
comme un prétexte pour une fois de plus
cultiver nos maladies franco-françaises
et Gérald armanin a annoncé quelque
chose hier il a dit qu'il interdirait
toute manifestation pro Palestine et que
les organisateurs serait
interpellé est-ce que ça veut dire quand
même que clairement l'importation du
conflit est là est-ce qu'elle est
compréhensible cette
décision difficile à dire elle va être
sans doute vécue comme un comme un dénis
de de de démocratie est-ce que ça va pas
au contraire provoquer des réactions en
sens opposé on sait comment comment on
réagit en en pareil cas c'est difficile
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'évidemment
soutenir la Palestine ne veut pas dire
soutenir le Hamas le Hamas est soutenu
en Palestine par environ 30 % des
citoyens il y a pas eu vraiment
d'élection depuis 2006 c'est très
difficile de mesurer aujourd'hui le le
voilà de faire de faire une équivalence
entre la cause palestinienne et la cause
du Hamas donc on peut soutenir
évidemment la Palestine il faut soutenir
la e il faut deux états pour deux
peuples il faut le rappeler même si
aujourd'hui c'est compliqué de le dire
dans un tel contexte il faut rester
optimiste sur cette solution uel Macron
l'a rappelé mais il faut vraiment
distinguer les deux causes la cause
palestinienne et la cause la cause entre
guillemets du Hamas ouais a il y a des
risques dans les prochains jours Pascal
en France des risques de violence oui il
y a des risques étant donné la
polarisation des attitudes au sein de la
classe politique française et même jusqu
que dans l'opinion quand on regarde les
premiers sondages qui ont été
effectués après le déclenchement de de
ce conflit donc il y a objectivement des
risques d'affrontement l'interdiction
des manifestations il y a eu par exemple
en Allemagne des manifestations
également qui ont été interdites si vous
voulez ce qui est très compliqué c'est
qu'on ne peut pas admettre en France
qu'il y ait des manifestations dans
lequel il y ait des éléments qui ou qui
fasse une apologie du terrorisme ça
tombe tout simplement sous le coup de la
loi euh et donc c'est très difficile
dans ce type de manifestation de
distinguer cela le soutien au Hamas se
réjouir des actes innommables que le le
Hamas a perpétré et de distinguer la
cause des Palestiniens quelque part si
vous voulez les palestinien qui en ce
moment en effet tombe sous le coup des
bombes qui euh pleuve à Gaza les ils
sont les victimes avant tout du Hamas le
Hamas a choisi une telle stratégie
d'affrontement qu'il était inévitable
qu'il y ait une réponse c'est ce qu'a
dit d'ailleurs le président de la
République une réponse forte et espérons
juste d'Israël on continue à parler de
ce sujet puisque c'est évidemment la une
de vos quotidiens régionaux ce
[Musique]
matin et Quentin la locution d'Emmanuel
Macron à la une de nos quotidiens
régionaux ce matin voilà on retient par
exemple son message à propos des otages
tout faire pour leur libération
c'est-à-dire à la Une de La Dépêche West
France qui titre sur cet appel aux
Français de la part du chef de l'État à
rester uni je cite encore même idée à la
Une de La Provence he pas de division
entre nous le journal a noté la
référence d'ailleurs d'Emmanuel Macron à
l'attentat de Nice en 2016 ou 86
personnes avaient été tuées un
rapprochement opéré pour ligaturer les
plai ouvertes é semblable note François
tonau dans les pages intérieures de la
Provence l'intervention militaire
israélienne à Gaza fait également la une
elle semble imminente voilà question
autour d'une repost titre l'Est
Républicain le feu saabat sur Gaza écrit
Le Télégramme à Brest les journaux
racontent la pluie les pluies de bombes
sur l'enclave pour détruire les
positions de tir du Hamas journal breton
qui explique que les soldats réservistes
sont en train de rejoindre leurs unités
galvanisé je cite par la colère depuis
le bouclage de ces journaux on a appris
que l'armée israélienne a ordonné ce
matin l'évacuation de tous les civils de
Gaza vers le sud de l'enclave
palestinienne d'autres sujets font la
une ce matin on parle de la mobilisation
syndicale contre la vie chère oui un
sujet important regardez le populaire du
centre à limoge limoge où l'on attend
des cortèges aujourd'hui des
manifestations organisées par la
quasi-ttalité des organisations syndical
quelles sont leurs revendications Haus
des salaires du point d'indice pour les
fonctionnaires revalorisation des
retraites des minimas sociaux meilleur
partage des des richesses et
conditionnement des aides aux
entreprises ou encore sauvegarde des
services publics et vraies politique
environnemental pou non je Tai plus mais
bon c'est à suivre aujourd'hui le retour
du débat sur le glyphosate et la
sampiternelle question Stop ou Encore et
oui effectivement avec cette grosse
bouteille de glyphosate de de
l'herbicide devant la Commission
européenne c'est une photo qui date de
2017 mais c'est toujours le même sujet
dans Ouest dans Sud-Ouest puisque les 27
étatsmembres se prononcent aujourd'hui
sur la proposition de Bruxelles de
reconduire pour 10 an l'autorisation du
glyphosate dans l'Union européenne le le
vote s'annonce serré il faut l'accord de
15 États sur 27 et que ces 15 États
représente au moins 65 % de la
population européenne bon on termine
quand même avec une info plus légère
c'est vendredi 13 c'est ça et on en a
que deux des vendredi 13 en 2023 le
prochain et bien c'est le 13 septembre
2024 pour l'occasion peut-être
allez-vous jouer au loto c'est ce que on
voit à la une du Courrier de l'Ouest le
journal danger qui qui raconte et bien
tous ceux qui rêvent des millions
peut-être vous vous allez jouer je sais
pas vous allez jouer je joue pas au
l'UTO j'ai pas de
chance on dirait pour gagner il faut
jouer c'est ça 100 % des des gagnants on
jouet
merci beaucoup Quentin Steve on remonte
votre livre Israël autopsie d'une gauche
1905 1995 CX édition de bord l'eau merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous merci
Pascal Perino d'être venu ce matin merci
à tous de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve lundi on vous souhaite un très
bon
weekend